there you go
my name is Stefan I'm an industrial
engineering student in the University of
Miami I was wondering if you could
describe how you think the world is
going to look technologically and
socially in say 50 or 60 years I'm
pretty sure people 50 years ago didn't
really imagine us having drones or
taking pictures or videos or stuff like
that so can you give us an idea what you
think the world's going to be like in
that 50 years thank you Salman first of
all I had no idea second he'll make some
give you some thoughts I very much hope
we're at a turning point we're at a
crossroads we're at a fork in the road I
very much hope in the next 50 years
virtually all of our electricity let's
shoot let's just start with 80% of our
electricity is made renewably from wind
and solar some geothermal some tidal
energy and we run the whole place
renewably that would be fantastic
this next thing isn't that hard to
predict there will be very few human
driven cars most automobiles in 50 years
will be automatic will be driverless in
the same way you get on a train at the
airport and you go from one terminal to
another you trust that train to do that
it stays on the track it just isn't that
far from now to have cars that drive
themselves especially in big cities I'm
very hopeful that the cars will almost
entirely be electric there'll be very
few fuel powered cars in 50 years that's
a tough prediction what I think in a
more grim or on the way to a poeple
apocalyptic vision the division between
the rich people and the poor people has
a very good chance of getting bigger and
bigger there'll be fewer and fewer
people controlling more and more wealth
I can easily see that happening but if
people like you vote and participate
then maybe that won't happen
and we can actually make the world more
fair and here at University of Miami
you're in the US the u.s. just went
through an extraordinary election like
nothing I've ever seen and not that it's
all about what I've seen but no one
anticipated such an remarkable outcome
analyses were done or polls were taken
to show that if everybody you your age
only your age
voted this would be Millennials and
Generation X people if only you had
voted the election would have
overwhelmingly gone the other way so I'm
pretty sure the Conservatives who are
clinging to the old ways of making
energy the old ways of distributing
energy and pretty sure those people
realize that they're going to age out
that their political influence will fade
quickly and this last election is almost
certainly their last last gasp it's
going to be a near run thing either in
the next decade or 15 years the u.s.
becomes the world leader in renewable
technologies or the u.s. just continues
to divide the rich in the poor and
global climate change gets stronger and
stronger and the ocean gets bigger and
bigger as it gets warmer and the quality
of life for a lot of people goes down
we'll see but man you've given me a lot
to think about I want you to change the
world
go get them settlement let's go
[Music]